philipp und ich haben uns überlegt dass
wir euch mal erzählen was wir gelernt
haben und normalerweise lerne ich immer
alles von philipp aber manchmal lerne
ich auch was aus büchern
lernst du viel aus büchern ich habe
gelernt ja in einem super tollen buch
von einer britischen
wissenschaftshistorikerin hellen
macdonald abendflüge und das sind eben
es ist
oft über vögel und mich interessiert die
natur ja gar nicht aber in diesem falle
war ich wirklich extrem dankbar dass ich
das lesen durfte unter anderem habe ich
gelernt dass die schwarze weg ameise um
sich zu paaren in die luft fliegt
geschwängert wird und kann 30 jahre lang
kinder gebären dass das weiß doch
eigentlich jeder jedes kind ich habe zum
beispiel dieses buch mitgebracht was du
kennst werner herzog dass der mann der
welt und der lerneffekt ihr war für mich
auf einer anderen ebene zu sehen dass
man auch unfreiwillig ironisch sein kann
also du musst vielleicht kurz noch sagen
um den es geht über skion oder der nicht
mitbekommen hat dass der krefelder das
gab es 1974 im philippinischen dschungel
dran war japan zu verteidigen und immer
sind die flugzeuge über ihn hinweg
geflogen
das eine war der koreakrieg das nächste
war der vietnamkrieg und das hat sich
natürlich erst hinterher herausgestellt
dass er immer dachte seien noch der
zweite weltkrieg es gibt in diesem buch
eine stelle wo er über die hauptfigur
sagt die sei also jetzt völlig ruhig und
gelassen diese figur ist erfüllt von
soldatischer manischer pflichterfüllung
das hat überhaupt nichts mit
gelassenheit zu tun das heißt wenn du
über diesen charakter hier sagt der ist
jetzt völlig stich gelassen dann ist das
eigentlich nur ironisch akzeptabel
ironisch ist dieses buch überhaupt nicht
kennst du trottel ort war eine in den
80er jahren eine wirklich sehr bekannte
us-amerikanische schwarze lesbische
frauenrechtsaktivistin
die auch lyrikerin war und hier sind es
von ihr versammeln und die hat schon
ganz früh die debatten aufgegriffen die
wir heute führen und sagt ebel vor allem
es gibt keine hierarchie in der
diskriminierung und dieses buch findet
würde dir wahnsinnig gut gefallen
tatsächlich weil sie für so vieles
plädiert was du hoch und runter betet
man lernt so viel aus diesem buch und
vor allem auch den perspektivenwechsel
mal in andere positionen einzugehen und
sie sagt eben sollte die gruppierungen
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen zum
beispiel haben die ganzen feministin und
der 80er jahre eben die schwarzen
feministinnen überhaupt nicht
reingelassen ihre ganzen debatten
sondern haben sie auch ausgegrenzt haben
aber die ganze zeit gesagt sie sind
gegen ausgrenzung also das ist sozusagen
ein sehr wenn nicht richtig verstehen
sehr kritische
position gegenüber identitätspolitik wie
ich sie ja auch vertretungen deswegen
ist es ja eigentlich nicht was du nicht
schon von mir gelernt
du hast es nicht so poetisch gesagt und
lernt irrsinnig viel wirklich ganz
großer verschenkt sicherlich nicht
unterschiede lebens und sondern
schweigen es geht natürlich auch um die
überwindung des schweigens durch das
schreiben jetzt was ganz anderes ich
habe ein ganz
exotisches es wird dir wahrscheinlich
gar million auf englisch mit was ich
gelernt habe nebst dem anderen aus
diesem buch ist ein neues wort nämlich
ökonomie das weiß was das ist nicola
topologie das ist die wissenschaft von
den ortsnamen gibt tatsächlich einen
akademischen zweig der sich mit der
zusammensetzung bildung und geschichte
von ortsnamen gefasst oder ohne darüber
gesprochen habe ich war wenn ihr ganz
viel unnötiges wissen erfahren wollt
doch kein unnötiges wissen zwar noch
perlen der weisheit also perlen der
weisheit bei steiner und dengler wie
jede welle
[Musik]